is our food becoming less nutritious
many people claim that the nutrient
content in our food has been decreasing
over the decades but is this really true
and should we be worried a study
published in 2004 looked at 43 different
common garden crops and how their
nutritional value had changed between
1950 and 1999 now what they found was
that on average the protein content of
those plants decreased by about 6%
vitamin C decreased 15% and vitamin b2
by a whopping 38 percent they also
noticed declines and minerals like iron
and calcium now there is some debate
around the numbers because well how well
could we really have measured those
nutrients back in 1950 but there is
still this concern that the food we're
eating today might be less nutritious
than say the same vegetables 50 years
ago several other recent studies also
suggest a pattern is emerging so if
we're witnessing a nutrient collapse
what's causing it one factor that many
people point to is depletion of the
soils given plants to draw their
nutrients up from the soil intense
farming practices were thought to be the
cause of nutrient depletion if you look
at micronutrients things like minerals
or there are decreasing levels in plants
but farmers have always put a lot of
effort into maintaining their soils and
using fertilizers to ensure that the
plants have all the nutrients they need
which makes that argument less
convincing we're still getting big
plants and they wouldn't grow that well
if they didn't have the nutrients they
need in the soil
so why else might nutrients be declining
one possibility is that it's selective
breeding if you look at crops like corn
today they're barely recognizable when
you compare them to their ancestors the
wild corn from which these were bred
basically since the advent of
Agriculture we have been breeding our
food crops for higher yields for
resistance to pests and changes in the
climate and by and large we've been
successful crops are now bigger and grow
faster than ever before but are they
more nutritious maybe we've accidentally
been reading the nutrition out of our
foods in pursuit of other objectives
it's tough to really assess how big of a
factor selective breeding is because we
can't easily compare this produce to the
same produce a hundred years ago or a
thousand years ago so we need something
else to be able to determine whether
it's selective breeding causing this
decrease or something else what would be
really helpful would be a plant that has
never been selectively bred where would
you find one like that
well this is where weeds come in handy
in North America there is a wild flower
called goldenrod it's an important
source of protein for bees but not
humans and so it has remained wild or
untouched by selective breeding but how
would you know what goldenrod was like
100 or 200 years ago the Smithsonian
Institute have been keeping hundreds of
samples of goldenrod dating all the way
back to 1842 using these samples and
samples they collected in 2014
scientists were able to compare modern
goldenrod with goldenrod from over a
hundred years ago and the results were
astounding they found that there was a
30% decrease in the amount of protein in
the goldenrod pollen over that period so
if it's not selective breeding what else
has contributed to goldenrod becoming
less nutritious over the last 150 years
or so one rather surprising idea was
that carbon dioxide could play a vital
role here we see in cross-section air
with its particles of carbon dioxide gas
enters the plant and makes its way into
every living cell co2 is like plant food
in the air it basically increases the
growth of all plants over the last
couple of centuries the level of co2 in
the atmosphere has increased a lot from
about 280 parts per million to over 400
parts per million today now that might
not sound like a lot but if you're
thinking of it as plant food we're
talking about an increase by almost 50%
and we can see the impact from space
it's called the greening of the planet
scientists have been tracking the impact
of co2 on plants via experiments called
face which stands for free air carbon
dioxide enrichment their experiments run
by injecting more co2 into the area
where plant crops are grown and they
find that wheat and barley rice and
potatoes they will grow faster if
there's more co2 in the atmosphere but
here's the thing they don't necessarily
become more
nutritious they simply put on more carbs
in other studies conducted in Japan and
China scientists pumped carbon dioxide
into rice crops to simulate the kind of
co2 concentrations expected in 50 years
time on average protein levels fell by
10 percent iron by 8 percent and zinc by
5 percent but a lower concentration of
nutrients doesn't necessarily correlate
with a decline in the plant's nutrient
contents it's called the dilution effect
so what does all this mean for us well
by 2050 scientists estimate that up to a
hundred and fifty million people in the
developing world may be on the verge of
protein deficiency due to the decreasing
levels of protein in their staple foods
so does that mean we should all be
taking vitamins and supplements well no
at least not yet because the nutrient
declines are small enough that you
should still be able to get everything
you need from a well balanced diet
including plenty of fruits and veggies
but the increasing levels of co2 and the
dilution effect may be exacerbating the
obesity epidemic the thinking goes like
this we feel full or satiated when we've
consumed a certain amount of protein so
if the protein levels are going down we
may have to eat more food more
carbohydrates and more fats to achieve
the same level of protein and that may
make us fatter while this is still a
contentious theory what is becoming
increasingly clear is that the changing
atmosphere specifically the rising level
of co2 is changing the food we eat
[Music]
hey I hope you enjoyed that I made this
video as kind of a companion piece to my
new feature-length documentary called
vitae mania all about the sense and
nonsense of vitamins and supplements you
can watch that documentary if you
haven't already by clicking right here
it's available globally except for
France and Germany because it'll be on
your TV on September 25th I'm really
sorry about that but I really appreciate
you making it possible for me to make
both YouTube videos and big
international TV documentaries it's been
a lot of fun and really I couldn't have
done it without you